hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before
friday monday morning podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
hey bill how come he didn't do the big
long stupid yell uh because i'm doing
two shows
two shots two shows a night for the next
uh
for eight days so for all you guys went
to public school like me that's
16 shows 16 hours of comedy there so i'm
trying to preserve my voice
because i want my [ __ ] jokes to be
pristine
in the great state of texas um
i'm having a great time out here as much
fun as you can have
they're in a [ __ ] pandemic
i did some cool [ __ ] i landed at love
field for the first time i always wanted
to land there
i always landed the bigger one but i
wanted to go through the airport but um
you know i didn't fly commercial because
i got kids and i got a
gig i have to do so which is [ __ ]
hilarious which means like half my money
just went out the [ __ ] window but it
is what it is
during a pandemic so we actually didn't
go through the airport we landed on the
other
side so that is the famous airport where
uh
jfk landed when the unfortunate [ __ ]
happened to him
that's kind of an understatement you
know he kind of had some unfortunate
[ __ ] happen to him
um you know my buddy was just telling me
that one of the kennedys retweeted
something about the cia taking out jfk
i mean it's that always made the most
sense to me
you know it couldn't have been the mob
because
then they would actually be bigger than
the government right
and it couldn't have been that i know
you know lee harvey oswald also i'm the
patsy
i just i believed that when he said it i
mean that's just me
okay and i'm also you know conspiracy
theorist type of person
i think everybody's full of [ __ ] you
know
everything's a [ __ ] conspiracy just
watching this donald trump [ __ ] as
he's tr he's raising all this money
he's done he [ __ ] lost not saying he
really lost
i'll go with you if they just go like
all right well they [ __ ] slid some
over to joe biden
um i would believe that in a second just
for the simple fact
that you know people are trying to make
money
okay and you can't make money when you
have no [ __ ] idea what the president
is gonna
is gonna do nobody knows what the [ __ ]
he's gonna do he's he's like he's going
bill belichick on us what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing out here
um so they want they want a nice
predictable warmonger um
with a face like jerry jones
but as far as that little jackass with
this [ __ ]
rifle i just don't i don't buy it magic
bullet and all of that [ __ ] i don't buy
it i think
um i think uh this is my [ __ ] theory
i just think
jfk was not
you know giving the big boys
what they needed so they could go out
and make their money so back in the day
it got messy nowadays they can just take
you out on social media they'll just
[ __ ]
photoshop some [ __ ] you know
say that you did something with the
russians you know they'll just [ __ ]
come up with some [ __ ] they'll cut and
paste it together
whatever you're not from this country
whatever the [ __ ] they need to do you
weren't born here
they'll just come up with some [ __ ]
and they'll get you the [ __ ] out of
there they don't they don't need to
whack you anymore it doesn't need to be
messy
plus you know the reality is because
convertibles are kind of like you know
it's kind of a chick car now
can't have a president and a convertible
hi did you guys see the real housewives
last night well what about
the first lady president then he could
stick her in a convertible
you know then feminists would all get
mad
how come they get a why do they have a
you know no they
actually go the other way and be like
you know see this is just this is
this convertible top is just the essence
of a woman
open emotionally where where the men
write in a
hard top just walling off their feelings
it's a phallic symbol i always love that
the skyscrapers and rockets and [ __ ] are
all phallic symbols and it's kind of
like well you know there's some
architecture
and design aerodynamics in there but if
you want to say it looks like a giant
dick you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'll go with it
um
[Music]
why couldn't we flip it around and say
you got penis envy
there's so much of that feminist [ __ ]
that's just hilarious to me like or just
female arguments
where they go oh it's a double standard
if a guy does it he's just stud
if a woman does it she's a [ __ ] well
first of all men have to talk women
into bed where women can just show up
with their titties out and they can get
some dick i mean that's kind of how it
is
right don't want to be crass but i just
was and there's also other double
standards that
level it off if a guy [ __ ] around he's
a dog
he's a piece of [ __ ] it's his fault if a
woman [ __ ] around it's the guy's fault
he wasn't giving her what she needed
emotionally
so this there's double standards that
work out for you hey listen i don't want
to
i don't want to start a fight here
between the men and the women all right
i want gay people to argue so here's no
kidding all right
um i watched some uh
i mean i just basically i just i
haven't done [ __ ] i essentially i go to
the venue
i do my shows and then i come back to
the hotel
and i study my french and i've been
watched speaking of french i watched a
movie on uh netflix called lost bullet
which i really really really enjoyed and
um i got to be honest with you i'm
getting pretty good about reading french
even though it's flying by but i gotta
tell you as far as trying to understand
when those people are talking
holy [ __ ]
i mean it is like a hundred times faster
than i can kind of keep up
but uh i've been sticking with it i did
duo i've done duolingo for 141 days in a
row
and then i got this really great app
um what the [ __ ] is it called here
pimsleur p-i-m-s-l-e-u-r
and um i don't know i just been doing
this [ __ ] we'll see if i stick with it i
always start to do it then i never do
but i think this one this time it's
gonna stick because
it's kind of i i follow some now i just
follow random people
on twitter and instagram just because
they're french
like i just sort of wrote some
friendship just to see what accounts
would come up and i just
followed anybody just because i want to
be reading it
and now i'm starting to watch like
french movies i'm trying to immerse
myself into the language
because i think it would be [ __ ]
hilarious to go to paris one day and act
like an ignorant american and
actually be able to understand what
people are saying or maybe you don't
even do anything
and they just look at your face and just
go you know this stupid american or
whatever the [ __ ] they would say
america unless it's a woman american
francaise uh
my wife would be uh francaise
madame all right um moving
plowing ahead here um yeah so i watched
that movie lost bullet
and then i'm also really big on renting
movies on youtube
they got a lot of good [ __ ] movies on
there um
i kind of i'm trying to find some
obscure like
um early 70s movies that are good
you know like the friends of uh whatever
the [ __ ] that movie was that i watched
that i loved
eddie coyle unbelievable movie
um and then i saw uh
i'm trying to think of some other ones i
just watched a couple of car movies
i literally watched a movie called the
car with james brolin
um josh brolin's dad i believe uh ronnie
cox who played bogamill
in um the beverly hills cop series
uh i just watched that movie you know
it's just interesting the uh i gotta
post
one of the lines i'll post the clip
it's basically a car that's going around
killing people
in this small town and it kills
you know it kills so many [ __ ] people
you'd think that they would get
you know they would turn to like the
feds or maybe try to get the army to
come in there to stop this [ __ ] car
but they don't
these uh cops in the middle of nowhere
they just try and stop this goddamn car
and uh they get mad at the car and all
these people are yelling at it
for whatever reason out of nowhere this
chick just yells out as the car is
driving away she just yells out
cat poo
[Music]
and i would put that line right up there
with one of my favorite
bad lines in a script that an actor just
gave
gave it their all is uh a great movie
uh called over the edge
i've talked about this before the kids
take over the school
they lock the parents in like the uh the
little auditorium
and they start trashing the school and
the local cops trying to get you know
they pulled the gates
blocked them and they're trying to get
out of there you know
and their kids are vandalizing the
school right i bet if i watched it now
now that i'm older i'd be like these
goddamn punk kids these parents need to
get them in order
but i was a kid i liked it like yeah man
trash to school
[ __ ] trying to teach us for free um
this woman grabs a giant globe and as
she's running past
the auditorium the cops on the other
side of the gate and she stops and she
looks at him
and she is holding the globe and she
just goes eat it you stinking pig
i don't know what that means other than
they were trying to stay with the pg
rating
um but whatever i'm making fun of that
movie a little bit i will tell you uh
if anybody can find out where that shot
because there's an opening scene where
there's
two people riding a bicycle through this
this um
this tunnel and like uh looks like this
southwest of this country it's [ __ ]
gorgeous um
[Music]
and then of course some [ __ ] [ __ ]
happens after that but it's
it's a cool movie man if you're just in
like a silly mood
you want to watch something then it's
also cool seeing josh brolin's dad josh
brolin is one of the coolest [ __ ]
actors ever
and you see his dad you're like ah
that's where he got it that's where he
got that swagger
um and also what i can't understand
is whenever they do a movie about the
70s like
now they never can do the hair right
like if you look at like james brolin's
hair with the stash it's like that's the
dude
that's the [ __ ] marlboro man that's
the guy everybody wanted to be in the
70s and that's the [ __ ] haircut
that's what you wanted to look like it's
right there on film
i know maybe when people get cast they
don't have time to grow it out but it
always just looks like they're wearing
stupid wigs
um but anyway
some cool cars in there some plymouth
furies
uh motorcycles and [ __ ] 10-speed bikes
from back in the day i'm a ch
really am a child of the 70s and then my
music is from the 80s
and i just been having a great time
there's a couple of uh burt reynolds
movies i want to check out too so that's
what i've been doing on the road
good clean fun um
we also got some the best [ __ ]
barbecue i think i've ever had
um let me get you the name of this place
i think it's called the pecan lodge
here in um dallas texas hold
the best [ __ ] brisket i ever had and
like they ordered that [ __ ]
got it for me and i ate it like an hour
later and it
you know because i was doing the show
and it was still unbelievable
i believe it's the pecan lodge i believe
it's the pecan lodge yes
um you got to have the brisket holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not like that thin cut it's like a
thick cut
almost like a small steak and it was
just the juiciest
brisket you know because sometimes you
know barbecue the thing about
barbecue is as far as my limited
knowledge is a lot of times it's not a
good cut of meat that's why they cooked
it low and slow
and then they would put like that sauce
on it to try to give it some flavor so
if people don't know what they're doing
like we had this other barbecue last
night and it did not travel well i'm not
going to trash the place to say the name
of it because that's not fair i think
you've got to go there and sit down
but um the pecan lodge holy
[ __ ] if you ever come to dallas that's
the way to go oh and love field too as
people will tell me has a little
aviation
museum i don't know if i'm gonna have
time to go over there
um i kind of just been chilling here you
know
watching movies they got you know
going to the gym making sure there's
nobody down there
um my shoulders are feeling good man i
actually
worked out uh yesterday
did like super lightweights and stuff
but it just felt good to get that
pump going again you know made me want
to go back to the 80s and put on my
spandex and only do my chest and my buys
no legs pencil legs over developed up
top right
walking around looking like you're on
stilts um
oh [ __ ] who's playing football tonight
[Music]
thursday night football it comes right
up
who do we got tonight
no thursday night football nfl game for
week 13. here's why
dude when jfk got assassinated they
still had the football
all right nfl week 12 overreactions this
will not be my homes in the chief's last
trip to tampa this season that's an
overreaction is what they say
wait the baltimore ravens were supposed
to have a full week of preparation
following their thanksgiving day matchup
against the pittsburgh steelies
six-time super bowl champion pittsburgh
steelers before kicking off nfl week 13
tonight
against the five-time super bowl
champion the dallas cowboys
when the hell was this written december
3rd okay
um however due to a coronis virus
outbreak that forced the league to
postpone their game against the steelers
until wednesday
which the steelers won 1914 the ravens
will have
a game moved for a second consecutive
week
instead of playing the cowboys at home
tonight the game has been pushed to 8
p.m
eastern time on tuesday with fox's
thursday night football broadcast team
joe buck
the voice of lou gagliardi on f is for
family and troy aikman
on the call um that's cool man
by the way speaking efforts for family
we just did the final table read
for ephes for family episode 44.
i cannot tell you how much fun i had
doing that show
writing those characters and all the
voice over actors
that um i really i learned so much about
acting i learned how to write a script
i met some of the best friends i've met
in my life and in this business
and i plan to stay in touch with
everybody i mean it's not over yet we
still have to edit do all that stuff
for a year for the next year it doesn't
come out i don't know when it comes out
sometime next year
[Music]
but i want to thank everybody who's
watched the show i think
season five is going to be our best
season we're going out with a bang
i'm really sad really legit sad that
it's over
but i will tell you this uh what i am so
proud of
is that it's not gonna have like a dip
um which is the number one thing you
want
is you want to leave him wanting more
and
i hope you guys feel the same way about
the show but i want to thank everybody
the great mike price everybody over
there
peter billingsley vince vaughn all the
vaughn's over there
victoria valerie now i'm gonna have to
name everybody and i'm gonna forget i'm
one of these days i'm gonna like next
year when we go to do this i'm gonna
have
uh i'll have the list of everybody and
it's gonna be like an oscar speech
because there's so many people i have to
thank
um it was an incredible ride thank you
to netflix and go mountain everybody was
just
been just amazing to be able to get to
do a show like that which was not even
on the radar when i started in this
business um
[Music]
you know that you could do a show like
that
the only place you could do it you know
it's funny and i used to go do it they
used to have these
i don't know they probably still do it
but they used to have this film festival
called
film festival called sick and twisted
animation
it's the first place i saw beefus and
beavis and butt
butthead um and a couple and just
they were playing frog baseball i think
was i don't know
so long ago christ it was almost 30
years ago and i saw it in
boston i went in there it was really
cool because it was like i had grown up
in such like a jock town
which was awesome because i love sports
and uh
my town was big probably hockey was with
the biggest thing
football and hockey and um
and i loved you know playing both those
sports didn't really play him organized
just sort of playing
with my friends but um
and then to move on in to get into like
stand up and stuff and then
meet all these artists who were into
movies and [ __ ] i think it was one of
them that told me about
that animation festival so i started
seeing like independent films
and all of that was a really fun time in
my life and i believe i went to all of
that [ __ ] by myself
because i was such a [ __ ] lunatic
um i wasn't a lunatic i had gone through
some [ __ ] and i just liked being alone
because you know
it was peaceful
[Laughter]
if that makes any sense so anyways we
got a we've done six shows here
and um i kind of blew up my voice a
little bit because
uh unfortunately there's a little bit a
little bit of traffic noise
you know we're in the middle of these
skyscrapers it's a [ __ ] killer venue
though
i'd love to see a band there but like um
i've been having a little i had a little
trouble hearing myself and i made the
mistake of like talking louder
and i kind of figured that out at you
know i started asking the crowd you guys
having a good time just their reaction
like okay bill
they can hear you you just can't hear
them
because the laughs are kind of going up
into the air
as far as where we're at so um last
night i kind of just adjusted the way i
was talking i think i actually had
better shows last night
[Music]
but i've been having so much fun and i
want to thank everybody who's been
coming out to the show
so and tonight
after i do two shows i will be at the
halfway point
i wasn't even thinking when my agent was
booking these
i was just so goddamn excited to come
out here and do stand-up
because you know i miss it you know and
i'm just like i gotten past
all the um
the big work i had this year you know
getting through that gig in new york
this
the pressure of that and getting through
uh had to write an episode of episode
family getting through that
i'm kind of on the other side of
everything
and um so my agent was booking this tour
and i just kept adding days and adding
shows
and this is taking me back i remember i
i did a run of shows at the wilbur
theater in boston
like 19 shows i think it was and i
remember i blew my voice out on the
third show and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i was doing two shows a night and
except one night i only did one because
wanda sykes
was doing the early one i want to say i
think she did the earlier one
on a saturday night right so i um
i remember i was so tired and my voice
was so
shot i was doing this bit about a plane
crash
and the bodies hanging from the trees
i know the sun's [ __ ] up whatever
so i was like just bent over at the
waist almost like
that yoga pose right we just sort of
grab your elbows bend over the waist
stretching your hammies
and i remember i would i
do that bit i was imitating the body
hanging from like a tree branch
i can't remember what the joke was right
so
that in that um
every show that joke while the crowd was
laughing and i was hanging like that
that was for me that was my little break
in the show where i would just be laying
there i would be you know
act like i was dangling from a tree it
was a nice stretch for the hammies
and i would always hold it for an extra
second or two
and be like ah little i had the storm
before i go back into this [ __ ] and try
to get through this
and um
but it was fun though it was fun and
it's amazing that people still come out
to see me so i'm psyched for all of that
uh the only thing that does stink is i
really miss my wife and my kids but
thank god for facetime and all of that
um
[Music]
you know i've been talking to my son and
his face lights up when he sees me and
he hears my voice
and i still you know i was really sad
because i've seen him every single
day of his very young life and these
were the first days i wasn't gonna
be there with him hug him and kiss him
and
try to make him laugh and all of that
stuff but uh
what's been cool is i've kept my streak
up made him smile
since he's been smiling i've made him
smile every every single day so i'm very
proud of that and um i don't know that i
was telling you that wolfgang
uh van halen song which by the way he's
got another one man
i posted it on my instagram stories dude
[ __ ] the riff is
killer [ __ ] killer and i i thought it
was like i thought
the song was in seven but um it was
funny i gave it to my drum teacher i'll
go i'm gonna figure out this time
signature and he's like all right
and i was like is it in seven and he
goes don't overthink it
and then i just wrote that means it's in
four lol
so it was um but anyway i got so much
out of that video that he posted
you know through the years
showing him growing up with uh how great
his dad
eddie was and in the end that voice
message
i swear to god i was like dude that is
the goal
right there you know if if you're a new
dad or if you're just a dad i
highly recommend watching that video and
seeing how it's done
and also just it was such a great video
too to see this other side
of this guy that i just knew was a
guitar guard
to be like wow man this guy understood
music
guitar piano
you know just underst he understood
being a dad at like the same level which
is crazy
so it makes me enjoy his music even more
then i'm also psyched uh some of the
stuff i'm listening from wolfgang he
doesn't sound anything like his dad
which is an incredible accomplishment he
doesn't sound anything like his dad and
from what i'm hearing his music is the
[ __ ] so i'm kind of excited i think he's
got an album coming out or something so
i'll be definitely downloading
downloading that um all right i gotta do
some advertising when i after the
advertising
i'm gonna talk to you about my ultimate
car collection which is really just a
bunch of trucks
because i am a truck guy it's what i've
realized
over the years and uh and if you're a
truck guy you want to be in [ __ ]
texas because everybody has one
um which is really cool to me all right
zendesk everybody customer service is
everywhere
buying stuff online calling your bank
using an app
to get a ride to the airport but even
great teams sometimes struggle to make
their customers feel
taken care of zen desks i don't say
zendesky zendesk's award-winning support
sales and customer engagement software
helps businesses
offer personal service at scale so your
team can concrete
can create conversational experiences
that keep customers happy
zendesk gives businesses everything they
need to stay connected with customers
this is perfect for during a pandemic
you want people relaxed when they're
relaxed they spend a little money
communicate seamlessly across all
channels email phone chat messenger
community forum
help center or social media zendesk
calls
zendesk calls that a conversational
experience oh zendesk calls that a
conversational experience
connected ongoing and natural customer
interactions
all made possible with zendesk
complete customer profile and unified
set of tools
that give you the context you need to
deliver great service in every
conversation
most support software requires experi
expensive consultants
and months of setup but with zendesk it
takes just hours
to get up and running on top of being
quick to implement zendex software
easily scales to meet
uh changing needs zendesk
gives organizations the flexibility to
move
quickly focus on innovation and adapt
to growth zendesk and with over 150 000
paid customer accounts and over a decade
of experience they've gotten pretty good
at customer service themselves
and asked uh see for yourself why the
best customers
customers experience are built with
zendesk uh
get started at zendesk.com that's
z zebra echo november desk
dot com slash bur all right
even yelling that zen desk tweaked my
voice a little i got it i got to bring
it down here
um all right stamps.com everybody
they've been with this forever
oh jesus um
stamps.com this holiday season dooby
dooby
do more people will be mailing stuff
than ever before
that means the post office is going to
be busy you don't have time for that
[ __ ]
stamps.com brings to post office and now
ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything uh from the
convenience of your home or office
with stamps.com this would be this would
be a great pairing with zendesk
uh mail and ship anything with from the
convenience of your home or office with
stamps.com anything you can do at the
post office you can do with just a few
clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money and deep
with deep discounts that
you can't even get at the post office
sorry um
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been supporting this show for
over seven years now
and if you haven't tried it what are you
waiting for stamps.com brings the
services of the us post office and ups
right to your computer stamps.com is a
must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices
an online seller fulfilling orders
during the record-setting holiday season
or even a giant warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamp stop comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer
to print official us postage 24 7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just schedule a pickup or
drop it off it's that simple with
stamps.com you get five cents off every
first class stamp and up to 40 percent
off with priority mail
mail and up to 62 percent off ups
shipping rates
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive post-its meters
stamps.com is a no brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 900
000 small businesses
already use stamps.com they're almost up
to a million businesses people
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at the post office this year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk with pro
my promo code bur b-u-r-r you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus
free postage and a digital scale um
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur
at stamps.com enter bur stamps.com
never go to the post office again oh
look who it is here we got one last one
last one here
it's hymns hang on a second
club soda kenny wants to know what time
i want to go to breakfast
uh come on come on what is it
why sometimes your phone just won't
[ __ ] turn
okay there we go
all right oh everybody it's him
you know men have tried all kinds of odd
unusual solutions to treat
erectile dysfunction um snake oil pills
herbs
hypnotism your dick is coming up
uh hims offers solutions grounded in
real medical science for hymns is all
about men's wellness
need help with erectile dysfunction hair
loss
hey or have a cold uh interested in
mental health or kovid 19 home test
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats erectile dysfunction
real science real solution to erectile
dysfunction
uh hymns makes it easy for him connects
you with a licensed medical professional
online
who can prescribe fda approved
prescription medical
medication sorry to treat what say it
with me
erectile dysfunction you get the same
active ingredient
as that expensive little pill but
without the expensive price tag oh they
got the bootleg [ __ ] over it for hymns
uh this could cause hundreds of bucks if
you had to go through a doctor or a
pharmacy
not so with hymns hymns makes it simple
and affordable
no embarrassing conversation i my dick
doesn't work
uh no expensive appointments uh just
answer a few questions online sir
your doctor's ready to see you for your
erectile dysfunction
something they would yell in a [ __ ]
waiting room um
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history and a provider will
confidently
confidently review uh if approved your
medic
your medication is shipped directly to
your door in discrete packaging and
shipping is free
no more searching online for answers to
questions for questions about
erectile dysfunction or sexual wellness
just go to for him's account and ask a
medical professional you can trust
why live with erectile dysfunction
when the solution can be so simple try
hymns today by starting out with a free
online visit go to for hims.com bird
b-u-r-r-e-d for your free gift that's
for hims.com
bird i m f-o-r-h-i-m-n dot com slash
b u r r e d here's a disclaimer
prescription products are subject i
gotta read this fast prescription
products are subject to medical provider
approval and requiring online
consultation with the medical provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember
that's for hims.com bird
b-u-r-r-e-d all right
let's talk about my woo dream garage
why don't you guys start sending in your
dream garages all right
what you would have um
let's see here what would you have in
your dream garage
or you and also of course your five if
you work with the public
public the five dumbest questions
people have asked you i'm trying to
think if people ask me five dumb
questions about stand-up comedy people
usually ask
really good questions um
all right here's my five and then i'm
going to breakfast here uh
i would have what i already have a 68
ford f-100 short bed
three on the tree i love that truck
i smile every time i see it every time i
get in it the sound of the door closing
starting it up i absolutely love it all
right
then as mentioned i would have a
two-tone
1986 full-size ford bronco
xlt lariat i wouldn't get the eddie
bauer because they always just do the
green with the tan top
which i respect but i like the blue and
white one
then i would get a 67 cadillac el dorado
in that that [ __ ] whatever they call
it the uh
something missed i forget what it is it
looks almost like an overcast sky
it's [ __ ] gorgeous and then the
latest one that i'm adding
is i get a 1983 ford f-150
4x4 short bed um
some sort of two-tone i'll post that
video to us
this guy [ __ ] redid one uh lady i
don't know who did it
it absolutely beautiful he had it was uh
that ford wimbledon white
and then he had like a little bit of
black trim and i just
love the front end on those four trucks
from 80 to 86
that was the first truck that i truly
fell in love with other than when i was
a little kid
when uh the milkman that's how old i am
there was a milkman there was a man
and he delivered milk and he was called
the milkman there was the milkman there
was the diaper man
you know it's all changed now now you
know they always they
now they have like i don't know what the
[ __ ] they have the [ __ ] heating lamp
guy
um and he used to come in this old milk
truck
and it had the same front end it was a
ford it had the same front end
as my f-100 that i have
um that's it that's my little dream
garage that uh
oh and then i also got to tell you i
would also like 80 to 86
full-size um the full bed
f250 in green when i was a kid there was
a uh somebody at high school used to
drive his [ __ ] dad's
f250 every once in a while he would
drive it to school i remember one day
he came to school after he'd gone murden
and the truck was all muddy except for
the windshield where the wipers were and
i thought it was the coolest [ __ ]
thing i'd ever seen and for whatever
reason i never forgot that
and i've loved ford trucks ever since
then all right
that's it that's my dream garage and you
know it's a little bit different
oh you know what else i would have i'd
have a harley um
not the road king the one that doesn't
have the bags on the side with white
wall tires
in black that would be it oh anna ducati
see it never rents it never [ __ ] ends
all right that's it that's my
my two motorcycles um and i would have
sort of the
i wouldn't have that one that when
people you know try to ride a motorcycle
around the world i wouldn't have that
big one
way up high i'd have whatever the one
that's sort of the cruising one where i
wouldn't fly off the back
all right that's it uh have a great
weekend yakunts and i'll talk to you on
monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday december 3rd 2012
and uh how are you this is going to be
as promised last week
and promised all over twitter that i
would have a special guest this week
stand up and rose bowl legend
the one and only the guy whose name i
would never mention on the podcast after
our first experience at the rose bowl
and here he is
the statue of limitations have run out
ladies and gentlemen mr joe bartnick
oh man thanks bill uh he's sitting there
holding that coffin
uh well i know i just coughed into the
this is uh this is fun
uh finally absolutely after all the
rose bowls and uh dude the rose bowl i
mean
you've given me probably the two
greatest thrills of my adult life
one obviously setting me up in my my
first six seconds on the ice with a goal
or setting up experience and then then
the road yeah when we were playing
pickup hockey
yeah pick up hockey and you gliding
around there like the great white shark
i got you out in front i i mean to step
on the ice
tap my stick rocky with tool hits me in
the slot
i go top shelf i should have just quit
then
why i end up you why i spent 500 bucks
on equipment
and only played once at well i played
like 10 times with like notepads
ian bagg finally gave me a helmet then i
bought all the stuff i played once after
that but it was you were getting scary
joe joe's like me he's one of those guys
who's watched hockey for a good 35 years
but never played we just didn't come
from hockey family so we both
figured we'd take up the game in our 40s
and we we both look like make-a-wish
kids when we were out there
dude the look on your face when you
scored you scored the goal
and you just put your arms up and you
just left them up and you said you had
this big grin on your face
and i saw it in your eyes you're like
this is what it feels like
this you would have thought you scored
one at the nhl level as opposed to
i i felt like his nhl level because i'll
tell you i was scared when i first got
there i think
you guys know ian bagg he's like six
five he's big he's on skates i'm like
canada and that he he can [ __ ] it like i
heard he skated with the canucks in
there he did he played junior hockey
yeah so i'm walking into the rink with
just literally like my street hockey
stick and those than the rented skates
yeah am i ready
and i walked in and i see him skating
around i didn't recognize him i'm like
holy [ __ ] what did i get into yeah and
then to step in to do that and i scored
another one real quick so i'm like i'm
looking for the i'm looking for the
natural hat trick
or hat trick in 10 seconds and after
that then bag cause there's no hit
league unless you can't stop
right uh like me
so the bag's like you're not getting
like a hat trick and then because i love
bag and he loves me
he just started cross-checking me in the
crease and then that was i never got and
i think i touched another puck
but uh like i said that's back when that
that pickup game is still
fun but that was that was hilarious like
the bad news bears it was like everybody
out there was a different level
so you could tell like how good somebody
was by how much equipment they had and
how new or how old it was
you went out there you had that [ __ ]
pittsburgh penguins
with no shield mask that's all i
remember and you kept playing dude you
were getting scary because you're like
[ __ ] cam neely's size
so that's what everybody was kind of
saying was like if that [ __ ] guy ever
learns how to skate
and doesn't learn how to stop like he
can't if someone's gonna get [ __ ]
killed well that's why i quit playing
roller hockey i played roller hockey in
san francisco for a season and like
10 like eighth game in i couldn't stop
on roller skates either
and i just absolutely buried
some kid about your size but not really
athletic like you yeah
you don't have to make it nice yeah
myself no no no no like you're
you're like you know you've been
climbing your rope and stuff i mean
you're
you're not like this was a little trying
to be actor in shape
and i just i buried him like when kevin
stephens had to buy a new face
after the islanders like that's how hard
i buried him and i'm like you know what
i'm not here to hurt people purposely
yeah i mean it's it's time to give that
okay you got a good heart
i do have i do have a good heart i
really do you're one of those guys if
you played in the nhl
you'd be that guy you'd [ __ ] knock
the dude down and the dude's laying on
the ice you'd [ __ ] the arm back and then
you'd be like no no that's enough he's
got enough
and then i would have a good dance
though after i won the fight
i'd do a nice hogan i'm sure i'd have
one of those where i would have been in
the stands once
well i know everyone has a good like uh
either junior a
or in europe some every good goon has
been
in the stands once like someone would
say something about malkin and like you
know some some mafia
heroin den in that you know uh magneto
gorst and i'd be up there swinging away
protecting his mom's on or something
like that you know
did you uh have you watched uh the [ __ ]
was i just think my i have like add
you've just brought up something
oh i know for fans you know because you
know hockey's like the rogue sport for
fans uh
who don't know what joe's talking about
well i'm gonna i'm gonna have a link up
to that that classic one where the
bruins
went up into the stands at the uh
madison square garden and mike milbury
who now does like commentating wearing a
suit
you actually watch him he takes this
guy's loafer off
loafers were big in the uh the 70s
speaking of which you actually still
have him because you're old school
he took him off he never hit the guy he
cocked it back he was going to hit him
with the heel of it and it was uh
it's it's just something that can't be
described so you have to you got to see
it these
these loafers are my guilty pleasure and
everybody remarks on them now because
i've
passed into the age where now i wear
loafers and don't give a [ __ ]
like i i i went to ross to buy some i
always buy my tickets at ross because
why not buy air jordans that were 140
for 29 bucks like i'm i don't need this
don't all like giant guys like you go to
those kinds of places like when i go to
like
like ross uh what for people on the east
coast what's it ross
uh dress for less [ __ ] for less whatever
the [ __ ] they call you walk in there
they actually have
shack size shoes in there for that six
foot eight guy who couldn't dunk
yeah and like neon green and purple
they're all
the craziest shoes it's always like that
bag of [ __ ] you get when your house gets
flooded
you get like those [ __ ] giant
sneakers that are like neon green
yeah abso [ __ ] lutely so dude i gotta
tell you speaking of the [ __ ] rose
bowl the granddaddy of them all i got uh
i went out and i got the tickets
you know every year that's my job i go
out i get the tickets and then i i rent
the [ __ ] four-door [ __ ]
dodge ram pickup to drive over there
dude i'm actually uh i've just
completely checked out of christmas
shopping and all that other [ __ ] all i'm
doing is thinking about that what do you
think about [ __ ] with wisconsin's in
it again
uh yeah you know we couldn't we could
it's going to be an ugly game
it's going to be ugly in the parking lot
now i mean there's some nice wisconsin
people i wish
nebraska i like them cornhusker girls
you've ever played in the brat in the
bronx face lawhead said like he he was
rooting for nebraska yesterday because
he said we so we can look at different
fat chicks this year
yeah the nebraskans are a little bit
they're like
younger a little healthier like they're
kind of like this like the playboy
centerfold kind of chicks
the the brazilian girls well you know
something a lot of times uh
when they get them they get them from
that sort of the uh
oklahoma nebraska right the bigger loss
though was ucla
because stanford has nice looking girls
but they're really
smart they're not the type of girls that
like hey let's get her let's take our
tops off at 8 a.m
[Laughter]
last year that girl last year with the
the [ __ ] uh what was it tequila with
the pickle juice
the dirty mexican oh my god is that what
they call that drink
they did yes they did oh yeah the dirty
sanchez
chest i actually walked around with the
mexican
the leaf blower that's what they call
that the leaf blower there you go
uh we actually walked i actually went to
like five different people's houses with
tequila and pickle juice
trying to explain them and everybody
thought i was uh like
you've lost your mind barney i'm like
yeah i mean obviously i did 30 years ago
but here's the this is great pickle
juice it's it's cost effective everybody
if you're saving money for the holidays
because you can get the most rot gut
tequila in the world
it tastes good if you chug pickle juice
with it afterwards if you chase it
because i hate i hate tequila dude
that's always not like i ever drank
antifreeze but if i ever did i always
it tastes like some sort of cleaner it's
really [ __ ] there's the amount of
people too who really like uh
just slam that [ __ ] i had somebody a
long time ago one of one of uh worked
for one of my managers that i had back
in the day and he
he [ __ ] drank tequila and he drank he
drank that [ __ ] like
you know like we drink crown and royal
like it was nothing
no i like i to this day dude as much as
a [ __ ] booze bag as i am
if you give me a shot at tequila i will
make a face like i'm in seventh grade
i just can't get that [ __ ] down oh
remember that girl actually she had the
[ __ ] overalls
yeah i remember badass in the [ __ ]
half shirt yeah i remember all of it
yeah he was good yeah i remember that
that was before it got a little blurry
well that i i in the chronological
history of the rose bowl
uh rou first one ever the epic the
the granddaddy of them all the one it's
it's like every great empire starts with
a big crime like that
that was the crime against she made that
was this the greatest that was probably
my funnest time as an adult
ever that there's wait and why was that
because i feel like we get just
as drunk every year but that there was
just something about
i think because it was all new yeah no
but everything worked out we walked in
there completely [ __ ]
hammered i remember i bought that that
50 year old guy a program
because he thought it was too expensive
and i was like let me get two
you like that i go you're looking at
you're looking at a big shot you're not
going to see a lot of things let's talk
like a [ __ ] idiot
we were smoking those cubans and we we
got in and somehow you still had your
cuban cigar
you could you have your ticket around
your next you bought the
the super duper ticket holder and they
just i'm a nerd i try to say
it was so many people squishing in that
they weren't even looking at me that i
was still smoking a cuban cigar there's
nothing about eating a steak
drinking a bottle of crown smoking a
cuban cigar
that makes you feel empowered to do
anything
and a lot of people listen to thinking
that you mean he means splitting a
bottle
every year joe shows up with two bottles
of crown one for us
and one for him and dude i heard jimmy
page you know that picture that he takes
where he he
puts the the jack daniels back like that
i already just stuck his tongue in the
in the hole there just it was just like
a
photo op thing you actually down the
whole [ __ ] oh that's considered a fifth
that's terrible yeah it's well it's the
regular sized crown but that's terrible
to know i didn't want to know that
well he made it up with the [ __ ] uh
the heroin abuse oh so i'm just
repeating something
from somebody in a bar who allegedly met
[ __ ] somebody well let me tell you
something mr in a bar
if you're gonna talk [ __ ] on jimmy page
i just make sure it's true because
that's something that's all i thought
that's not a rumor that should be like
you know jimmy page uh he's not really
drinking that's like
jimmy page's jack james is really iced
tea it's like when you find out when
dean martin like no dean was drunk
most of the time just when he was
already gone like the producer
like let's put a little let's water this
one down yeah
because that now people want to revisit
his like oh dean was drinking iced tea
like yeah and the hookers were fake like
give me a break like these guys were
partying
their asses off and they could they had
a good buzz going look
you got to know me most of my [ __ ] is
just stuff that i just repeat [ __ ] that
somebody tells me
and then that's it that's i don't i
don't research it no but we do drink a
lot
but i i i had lie ahead though la head
is is the cook
lawhead's looking at uh a barbecue uh
brisket or some [ __ ]
game game uh game two that's it i think
the other thing too just the planes
coming over
when you're when you are bombed there is
nothing better than two
uh two like f-16s flying right over your
head that you're not expecting i mean
that was just like yeah uh i also think
those are like two like
historic teams too it's like we went the
first year and it was usc
versus penn state and penn state gained
six
total yards in that game and i
celebrated it like they won
40 to nothing well that's because you
yelled at that [ __ ] [ __ ] was sitting
in front of oh she got mad at you with
the cigar
yeah yeah the funny thing was was i mean
i my sister went to penn state my sats i
could have taken them six times i
wouldn't got into penn state if you
added them all together
but i got like a 390 or a
407 combined and i took a prep course
too
but we were like actually the day i was
gonna take the sats i
uh the night before my uh a friend of
mine's like hey
come help me collect some money so i
didn't get a good night's sleep before i
took my test
oh that's right back in the day when you
were in pittsburgh yeah back in the day
yeah we won't tell them in those stories
but that's that's that's my essay that's
why i didn't do too good on the sats you
know yeah is it those that that stuff
about uh
collecting money back in the day when
you were you were the uh
the [ __ ] dude they brought around the
enforcer that you don't get into that
stuff ever huh
no it's just fun it's just it's just it
was just for beer money
[Laughter]
you know something that's why that guy
that one year the first year
the wife of that lady after she gave you
[ __ ] she said something about your nose
and then you said you need to lose about
20 pounds before you talk to me
[ __ ] and then she turned to her husband
and
he turned around took one look at you
and then started jawing at me you know
i said like i said like 40 though she
was a big ugly woman the thing was
i'm a nice guy bill and i and if you
just would have said hey can you please
put that cigar out i always said
oh my god oh my god i actually i snuck
this in
i'm i'm sorry i didn't sneak it in i
just forgot i was smoking it i'm like uh
sorry i'll put it out you had it chomped
in your mouth like you were a general
surveying your conquered land i it was
like i was it's like i was a it's like i
was a
a boxing aficionado from the 1920s yeah
and she said just put that goddamn thing
up
she came out of the gate and then i was
just like well that's uncalled for
and that's what i said you need to lose
about 40 pounds to talk to me
and then i thought we were getting
kicked out but in defense of her though
like we were so you realize how [ __ ]
ridiculous it was
well first of all i fell on that [ __ ]
old lady
sort of fell into her yes and nobody
helped me up and i had to push off her
and i felt folded her in half
and then you got to the seat and then
you had the [ __ ] cigar
so already we were kind of respectful we
have to have a little bit of empathy
here
to paint the picture of where we're at
though too and if you ever see a college
football game
where you see the stands and it's like
oh my god there's a hundred thousand
people wearing
red or orange or green yeah yeah yeah
there was literally 50
000 people wearing usc colors and just a
speck
of me and bill just wearing like neutral
nothing yeah
but they knew we were for penn state
immediately once that lady started
yelling at me i was just i mean i'm not
a usc fan anyway so i uh
but i i did like usc because the girls
were so
hot and then we met a guy that
was such a usc fan he literally had the
uh the trojan
outfit and let's put on the trojan
helmet and hit the helmet that's the
beauty of the rose bowl i think that
makes it so much fun is hey it's
80 degrees outside everywhere else the
weather sucks
and the teams are so happy to be there
there's nothing really on the line
no i mean other than you know your own
betting purposes so everyone's just
happy to be partying
it's not like in your if you're in
pittsburgh and i mean like
some of the best tailgates or green bay
or any other city where it rules there's
tension in
the air yeah and it's 20 degrees outside
this is like it's sunny everyone's happy
to be there throwing the ball
around it's just it's the way it should
be you told me something the other day i
thought was it because you know you know
i'm a big
like maniac as far as going around to
different stadiums and all that like i
love all of them and i got a chance to
go to three rivers
before they knocked it down i didn't see
a steelers i saw a pirates game there
when they honored willie starjo
literally like two weeks before he died
oh pops and i remember it was a cubs
game and i was sitting down the right
field line and sammy sosa was still
playing
and uh but you were saying your dad
has had season tickets since the stadium
that they played in before three rivers
which was what i always forget yeah my
dad
has had tickets since forbes field and
then they went to pitt stadium or
something for a couple years i may have
this reverse but he's had them like in
both of those places
then they went to three rivers and my
dad sat exactly
on the 50 four rows from the top
four rows four rows from the top and he
sat there and he he watched them go from
sucking i mean you guys were the
absolute you know you're one of the
original nfl teams and you were a
doormat for the good what 30 40 years
it's finally come back to where now
we're like better than we suck
like like i was born in 1969
that's the year they drafted joe green
i'm 43
for the first 40 years they didn't win
like four games
now we finally now it's like we've been
better than than
than we've been than we sucked when i
was a super bowl era yeah because when
i was like five or six my dad was taking
the games that's when it was all steel
workers so you went there
and you saw lambert ham i saw
every i saw the game where bradshaw spun
in the ice
playoff games yeah i mean the greatest
thing was we were
our our side was the steelers that was
on the cover of sports illustrated i
think yeah
our side was on the steeler bench so the
greatest thrill ever
is the steelers would kick off
and then this then okay the other team
would have the ball
one two three and out and then the
steelers come off
to our side and then it's like watching
the hall of fame induction committee
come off
i mean that's the steelers and the place
how many of them
there's 11 guys on defense like six of
them maybe uh well
four four four on defense and uh sure
dude elsie greenwood
is not in yet he isn't no it's mean joe
lambert ham and mel blunt
and then it's on the offense it's
webster swann stallworth
bradshaw franco and of course the
emperor chuck no
and they used to be that that's nine
nine out of here 22. that's almost
half the guys on your [ __ ] t your of
your starting team made the [ __ ] hall
of fa
on a football team well the thing was is
in for years they wouldn't put swann
or stallworth in and it used to be the
old manager of the punchline jim cornett
knew at like five in the morning when
i'm a bottle of crown and you want to
get me to argue for an hour
just say i don't think lin swan should
be in the hall of fame
[Laughter]
that was always it's almost like now i
can die in peace like the ranger fan you
know what that's like that was the first
time
we brought up you and i discussed all
samuelson and cam neal and you like
yeah i mean uh you know i didn't think
off was that bad a guy i was like you
got it
and you what's funny about you is you
just don't ever lose your cool
you just sit there and just be like hey
yeah you know which was making me
[ __ ] madder and mad i remember we
were over [ __ ] jimmy doors
and jimmy was killing everybody playing
ping pong oh he's taken in between
jimmy was [ __ ] talking [ __ ] too he's
just i'm just returning the ball bill
that's all i'm doing i'm just returning
the ball and he put all this [ __ ]
spin on it
i get my ass kicked over the democrats
must have been losing that year
don't play door when the republicans are
in the white house they'll take it out
on you
exactly so we got in that epic fight but
you know
i'm trying to think so the first like
nfl game you went to you he brought you
there when you're like what four or five
years old
yes there was like 10 10 no women no
women ever
in like just 10 boys that were lucky
enough to have
i went with my dad and my grandpapp and
that was the original curtin the
original
everything so wait a minute now can you
remember did you ever see o.j simpson i
mean it's a franchise
no i want to hear some of the guys you
saw because the first game i went to was
like i'm in the 80s i saw the guys like
dan marino
i saw jim zorn i saw guys from like left
over 70 guys and all the 80 guys when i
when i would go to the patriots but like
70s guys that's when i collected
football cards that's when they were
like gods to me so
can you remember anybody uh anybody you
saw earl campbell then oh yeah i saw
errol campbell to me still the greatest
running back i've ever seen because he's
the only guy that i was when i was a kid
i was ever afraid of
like when i was a kid the steelers were
like the globetrotters
like they never lost like when they lost
in 77 to the orange crush
in denver and mean joe my favorite
steeler obviously
he punched a guy in his stomach and got
thrown out it ruined christmas
like i still believed in santa claus but
the steelers losing and
and joe getting tossed out it was like
christmas was ruined that was such a
[ __ ] up year that was the year with
craig morton and those guys right uh
yeah that's next week they beat the
raiders
yes john madden yeah madden and then and
then they got crushed by the cowboys
which is such a joke
oh the team the team that decade
whatever you never beat anybody for real
when it ever really mattered dallas they
were never called the team they were
called america's
america's team yeah that's like well
what america's team means is that you
have fans in every city it doesn't mean
that you're the best team
well people take that the wrong way well
for years though it's like they always
revisions
you know this and that you know and it's
like lin swan always says
the game gives you moments right it's
what you do with those moments
and jackie smith you drop the ball you
must be the sickest man in america
bless his heart he's got to be the
sickest man in america
i gotta put that clip up there too that
was like dude i gotta tell you something
though
when i went over to uh uh stockholm
uh sweden and i was totally jet-lagged
some [ __ ] steeler fan
put all four of the steelers super bowls
in their entirety
i don't know if they're still up on
youtube it was the [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
gotta tell you something about the
dallas cowboys 1976
they had you guys beat they played marty
ball in the
they started the game with the [ __ ]
reverse on the kickoff
to [ __ ] uh hollywood henderson he
runs up the sideline
roy jarrella knocked it knocked him out
of bounds he took a knee to the ribs he
missed like three field goals because of
that [ __ ] play
and tom landry got all [ __ ]
conservative and shut his offense down
no ensued to kick off and let it in the
hands of his defense
[Laughter]
i really like i mean yeah like those
games really
don't to me those who like the bet like
the best super bowl i ever saw is just
as far as two powerhouse teams
was that 79 won the the steelers versus
the cowboys and the two
that worst uh uh match ups two of the
worst matchups
that were almost great [ __ ] super
bowls was if the [ __ ] raiders beat
the stupid orange crush that year
they were defending super bowl champions
and they would have gone up against the
dallas cowboys
with a rookie tony door set now how much
[ __ ] better that
said a stupid 27 to 10 game and then in
when my stupid patriots we beat the
[ __ ] miami dolphins the miami reason
why the bears didn't go
undefeated was because the dan marino
beat him on monday night football
beat the 46 defense so they were 15 and
[ __ ] won
it would have been the rematch dan
marino defended the undefeated dolphins
that super bowl would have happened but
the stupid [ __ ] patriots
we went into the orange bowl won for the
first time in like 20 years
and then we go in there and just we got
re i think we got raped we literally got
raped
and i hate the i hate the [ __ ] on the
pittsburgh guy
who i love but he should let peyton get
the touchdown that was a disgrace when
he gave the fridge the ball really
yeah you're gonna give the fridge the
ball because the fridge is the fridge
because they got because they got caught
up in that super bowl
as opposed to like walter payton
who was playing on like two and 14 teams
or two and 12 teams when he started
because they didn't have four when
everyone still ran the ball like the sec
when football was about whether it was a
man's game and it's not like
let's spread everybody out and get a
pass interference oh can we talk about
that
i got to read some advertising here real
quick but we got to uh we got to talk
about that because uh i know you are
definitely on the same page as me when
it comes to uh
this past interference [ __ ] so let's get
the advertising out of the way here
everybody stamps.com you know the deal i
read this every week uh your second
going to the post office would you like
to have the post office in your house
if any time of the year you're going to
sign up for stamps.com this is the time
of the year to do it
the holidays are coming up you literally
don't have to go to the mall you go to
amazon.com you buy all your stuff
they send it to you and and with
stamps.com to give you a little scale
you can print out um you can print out
actual postage for the boxes stamps
letters anything you want to do you
never have to go to the post office
again
uh what do we got here i use stamps.com
anytime
i'm on the road and i send out my dvds
it's it's it's the greatest thing ever i
can literally do it at one in the
morning
and uh right now there's a special offer
when you use my last name burr b-u-r-r
you get a no-risk trial plus 110
bonus it includes a digital scale and up
to 55 dollars
in free postage they're literally giving
you 55 bucks
during the holiday season so don't wait
go to stamps.com right now before you do
anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bird burr
that stamps dot com enter bur for the
love of god
do yourself a favor during the holiday
season bring the post office into your
home
go to amazon.com order your presents off
of that
and then just get a beer turn on the tv
and laugh at humanity when they do those
stupid commercials
now they do those stories on the news
about people getting trampled at a
walmart
all right there you go and amazon.com
real quickly if you guys want to support
this podcast
uh just click on the banner ad on um
the podcast page my website anything you
buy
amazon.com will kick me a little bit of
a percentage and then i kick a
percentage of that over to the uh the
wounded warriors project so you support
this podcast
and you support the troops can you do
any better than that i don't think so
and once again for this holiday season
we have the wonderful man great
system what is the man great you ask
they are 100
made in america cast iron grilling
grates that are revolutionizing the way
people grill
basically when you buy a grill um
they usually give you you know they give
you grilling grates they have those
little skinny
grates on them and you can't get those
great marks that you see at the
steakhouse
this just basically upgrades your grill
it's like ripping
out the four cylinder you have in your
car and slamming a 454 in there that's
basically what it is
um they got that nice thick grilling
grates
uh it's named one of 2012's best
grilling accessories by men's health
magazine
man great so the perfect gift this
holiday season click on the man great
banner
on the podcast page of billboard.com for
their 19.99 holiday special
20 bucks you're renting you're out there
you go dad
thanks for raising me i love you son
um remember each monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush
good lord they actually gave me one of
these they're awesome
i swear even the apocalypse comes down
you can melt this thing down
and get you 20 bucks back or at least
slam a zombie over the head with it
and they're going to give you a brush
you're out of your mind not to do this
again that's the man great grills
enhancement system ordered today on the
podcast page of uh
billboard.com okay all right back with
the legendary joe bartnik before we get
into this
aside from the fact you're one of my
great friends both in and out of this
business uh we're here to actually
promote joe bartnick has a new
stand-up cd uh hour-long
cd um that he's going to be releasing
off of all things comedy our podcast
network called salute
um tell the uh tell the fine folks about
it oh it's a fun cd recorded
live at the punchline san francisco it's
about 15 minutes of bartnik classics uh
it was so i can hopefully bury some of
that material i've been lagging around i
need some new stuff everyone's like
we've heard that 10 times like well you
keep coming back thanks but um actually
buy it on amazon it comes out tuesday
help
bill help the wounded warriors and don't
go out in traffic i'll tell you what i
was just in traffic yesterday going to a
gig and i was like
haven't people figured out amazon yet
like you can just sit at home
in your underwear it's like they have
your your your
they have your master card they have
your sister's address you just go boom
boom boom
and that is it that's it yeah it's
amazing but yeah
it's uh called salute like instead of
cheers us italians go
salute that's right and since i'm a big
drinker and a lot of the jokes are about
drinking and
one way or the other um it's good first
time i've ever heard salute was
on some live old uh sinatra album
i heard it was with him with the count
basie orchestra and they brought out a
drink
somebody said something and he said
salute gin donos i get him with some
italian [ __ ] i don't know what he
laughed or whatever it was just like
it just seemed like even just in that
moment on the record it just seemed like
it was so much better that like uh
i don't know it was just like if you
went and saw frank it's not like
somebody would take out a [ __ ] iphone
and then film it and then if you didn't
make it you could see a clip of it
it's just like you it was such a [ __ ]
everything was just such a [ __ ] event
that's why like you know why i'm sitting
here being a total geek about listening
to you
going to those you went to nfl games in
the 70s through the 70s that was like
the golden age
of nfl football like the level of
quarterbacks that were in the league
stabler bradshaw starback
fran tarkington uh who else was somebody
even but even the shitty quarterbacks
like ken anderson
or brian's site dan fouts
is amazing but even like that even the
back of the man pastorini
yeah dante pastor like like don strzok
john strock would be a playoff
quarterback nowadays
oh the way they [ __ ] throw now yeah
they don't even run for four yards so
those guys will throw for 300 yards
and they're literally like you know 42
for 48 you're like oh my god the
accuracy it's like no they're throwing
four yard [ __ ] passes
you're not allowed to touch a wide
receiver i mean think think of what
swann would do now they couldn't touch
him
i mean they used to just try to abuse
him every second did the raiders
like you know hit him in the head swan
play with concussions every week it's
like
or the mel blunt rule which if you can
somehow find this guy's
footage on the uh on on youtube of the
1976 super bowl
mel blunt just beats the [ __ ] out of of
golden richards the whole [ __ ] game
golden riches almost is crying in the
end of it and he finally gets so fed up
in the fourth quarter
he punches mel blunt back and mel blonde
just did i think it was a forearm shiver
or something to his ribs
and uh golden's laying on the ground
almost crying
no flag and like the ref saw like the
the [ __ ] elbow and stuff it was just
considered football it was a man's game
it used to be football well it used to
be football was like the
12 like the 10 guys in the bar you
wouldn't mess with
those guys played football now it's like
the 10 guys who when they were 15
started taking
steroids and like they went through all
the best schools they got recruited and
they
they did good in the combine and blah
blah blah it's like because the
the guys have played the other you don't
even see me i'm just bitching about the
rules i still think that those guys are
[ __ ]
the maniacs man i just think like the
level of like
like the money and there's so much at
stake now that you can't just be going
down to the bar drinking a 12 pack and
then going out and playing you your your
high school football game friday night
you know
you really got to take it straight but i
think the i think in the 70s those guys
were way more
outlaws they were the outlaws the
steelers i mean like
ernie holmes shot at a police helicopter
and rooney brought a brought a bag of
money up to cleveland like i let him off
the hook
like it was like that type that wouldn't
happen now now they should nowadays you
have rape
you have uh rachel nichols outside the
outside the facility
we don't know what's wrong with ernie
[Music]
i mean it's like i just read that big
espn book that like thousand page book
i'll give it to you
um and it's all like behind the scenes
it's like you know any way you paint it
i still hate susie colbert
she despicably did not kiss i would kiss
joe willie namath on national tv
why would you disparage joe willie
namath it's like it's broadway joe
everybody loves the ladies the poor man
had to go to rehab he was embarrassed
like you couldn't
always funny was the second he started
talking you knew he was hammered
yeah he was just he just had that
[ __ ] i can't feel my nose
glow look on his face but it's joe
namath he's allowed
i know and he was back there with his
friends you know what they were doing
you know they were talking [ __ ] going
come on guys you know if we were healthy
we'd [ __ ] kill this team you know
they were having a good time
and all of a sudden he's talking to some
[ __ ] lady and you know him he went
back to the 70s
he was back at the playboy mansion well
she grabbed him did joe come over here
and she grabbed he was like what's he
going to do
i really want to kiss you
oh i love joe i follow him on twitter
he's the best i love that i just i love
joe he's the he's joe name
that's that's one thing about pittsburgh
too it's like you know and you hate when
i go off
but you know johnny you basically
invented football no no no no i just i
give you [ __ ] about the amount of times
that you quote
like i don't give a [ __ ] what situation
we could be in the middle of the desert
like running out of water and you'd just
be like well you know one time mike
wagner said
stallworth
my two favorite sports quotes are glenn
swan the game gives you moments my other
one is actually
i told it to john madden's face and he
lost tell that story tell him all right
okay so we're out in a business park me
and my buddy the captain out in
like an hour west east of oakland which
is basically if you're not
on the coast in california you might as
well be in texas right uh this is like
this is actually where they shoot the
sons of anarchy
uh it's just the badlands of california
hey we're out there
uh i'm probably dropping off a bag of
weed to a friend of mine or something
but we were there around lunchtime
and uh always saying we see this massive
force coming out of a diner and
john's huge and he's wearing like a big
winter coat because it gets cold there
it's like 40 did you recognize madden
immediately
immediately and it would be like hey
john so i'm going to go in the captain
like hey man
like hitting him like look look look
look and all of a sudden so
anyway we start walking and he's like oh
my god so
they're going hey mr madden or like hey
hey
what was was he freaking out he's just
that guy to be yeah
i mean the captain at noon in an office
park it's like
it's like an office park we're getting
you know what's what these guys want
yeah so he starts walking really fast
like i'm getting away from these guys
i'm trying to go to his car
yeah he's like not fun with his keys but
he's trying to hurt with his keys so
then
so then so he's totally ignoring us just
like maybe these guys will go away i'm
gonna
blow my rape whistle like get away and
then i just yell out my favorite quote
actually which is
he told his super bowl pre-game speech
was this will be the greatest day of
your life
only if you win so you yelled at that i
yelled at him
right then he turns around and goes oh
hey fellas how you doing
and he showed us his super bowl ring we
went over and shook his hand and then
i'm not an autographed guy and
until like a year ago i wasn't even a
picture guy right but you kind of have
to do that now so i'm just like
it was just the thrill and then
literally we got in our car
and just called the first thousand
people we could talk to like we just met
madden we just met
man but i used that landlord myself for
like
big sets or big shows or big appearances
or something is like
oh that's what you used to psych
yourself yeah like this will be the
greatest day of your life
only if you kill only if you kill that's
hilarious
[ __ ] like yeah i i gotta admit like
um i'm i'm
fighting really hard not to become the
uh the crabby old guy
sitting there talking about how the game
used to be and i i think you know
i understand they got to do what they
got to do you understand dude this this
future football they're going to start
with the linemen
standing up so they don't slam their
heads together well i what i understand
is that you know what you want to live
until you're 70 drive a bus
you want to you you want to have baby
mamas
and mansions and drive cars and be on yo
mtv raps
then you're gonna die when you're 50.
and that's the way it is
if you don't like it play in this cfl
like i mean that's just that's just
that's football
see that's the thing bill that's what i
grew up on i grew up on
that that's it's just i still enjoy it
hell i work for the nfl on fox it pays
me i love i get to take it i watch every
game
it's still good it's still better than
watching 98
of everything else but it's not they
third one you got five wide receivers in
the game
that's not football right and i mean
that's what i love about me
you know like and all these tricks and
like chuck know i'll call chuck know
again or
for the you know like you can fool some
of the people some of the time
but in the end it comes down to blocking
and tackling
and that's football it's about lining up
it's the oklahoma drill
you know it's about they didn't even do
you you quote steelers the way like a
jesus freak quotes like
scripture well nfl films to me chuck
knoll 316.
to me if you grew up in pittsburgh if
you're from pittsburgh in the 70s you
can jerk off the super
you can jerk off to nfl films it's that
great
in san francisco i was roommates with
the kids that's the greatest run in the
super life you guys won
four and six years four and six my my
old roommate uh one of my old roommates
who was a complete
uh art guy and drew and was sensitive he
probably wrote poetry i don't know
but he hated football but he just loved
the cinematography of nfl films
i mean that's that's how great it's
almost like it's almost like regular
football if you just watch a game like
whatever you're going to watch
whatever today it's not as good as
watching the nfl
films version of it and if yeah nfl
films
i always forget the guy the voice of god
oh john fasenda
yeah what the autumn wind is a raider oh
yeah
[Laughter]
you know it was great you ever heard
already uh already lange
yeah yeah yeah oh all the time i i love
that nick and artie that's the best
when he quotes that oh yeah when i went
and i did nick can arty show it's such a
if you guys aren't listening to it
you're out of
out of your mind if you just want to
listen to two people talking sports and
even if you're not into sports you're
just going to love listening to her
because it's just
just guys guys it's [ __ ] great and i
was sitting out uh
waiting to go in and he went into his uh
his impression of that the autumn wind
is a raider
can't remember how the [ __ ] it goes and
he just did the whole poem
and uh he [ __ ] it's just his delivery
because he's a [ __ ] great actor too
man you know i mean
oh he is he's he's i mean i love already
life i mean are you laying his
his football jokes on his uh jack and
coke special
is the greatest when he when he rips on
the eagles that's just the funniest
thing ever i made kevin shea watch and i
taped it i got to see it's just funny to
do a chunk on the eagles
and his stand up special yeah dude my
buddy paul verzi said one time he goes
you know what's [ __ ] weird is
everybody watches sports for the most
part we say everybody i mean the masses
watch real men yeah but but no people
who you're going to talk to watch sports
not that the guy with that i just love
how we define anybody who's into our
[ __ ] real guys
guys that you like if you're wearing a
hat just because you think it's cool
uh and like you're trendy like you know
i'm not going to talk to you anyway
like that's just how i view stand-up
like i like the guys who i would be
drinking with
i don't like the guys who i wouldn't be
drinking with and that's just the way it
is
no some guys are that's why i like
hanging out with you because i need uh
over the years i've gotten a little more
[ __ ] uh little
some of your bartnik stuff is rubbed off
on me because i'm one of those [ __ ]
i'm like you know i'm a liberal i'm one
of those empathetic people and let me
see the other side of this [ __ ] a lot of
people wouldn't believe that listen to
this podcast
well that's like go ahead i'm sorry but
i [ __ ] uh you know it finally i've
gotten to the point
of i will actually now like if someone's
a [ __ ] dick i'll just be like all
right that guy's a dick but it still
won't stop me from i'm trying to
understand
why they're a dick but you you like
you're just so
[ __ ] efficient with that [ __ ] like i
i know a couple guys like you
in my life where it's just you're just
real efficient you size somebody up
and the second you think that they're a
dick you like [ __ ] that guy
and you don't give a [ __ ] about whoa
maybe his dad left you don't give a [ __ ]
you just like [ __ ] him
i don't know i mean i feel bad for him
if his dad left i feel bad well you know
what i feel bad for people who lose
their mothers
because and just like not to be tragic
the kansas city thing that's what's sad
is like some kid doesn't have a mother
but uh that's the [ __ ]
i didn't want to get into it because
it's just a sad topic but uh
uh oh sizing people up well i grew up in
bars my grandfather owned and ran bars
and uh so everything in a minute why the
[ __ ] wasn't that the name of your
special
joe bartnik i grew up in bars if you
somehow did a picture
if you're sitting there on the stool i'm
sorry i'm interrupting your great story
go ahead no no no but that's so you know
when you're when you're like four years
old
in pittsburgh in in like you know the
70s in bars
you can size people up you you
understand people's mojo in about a
second
if they're how old were you when they
when you were getting brought into these
bars oh like three four five six my
grandfather always had three
he was like norm he had a seat in every
bar he'd go and people like hey hair
eagle everybody harry his name was
dominic
but he was like the original guy that
would say dude because he couldn't
remember a million people's names
so he would just go hey hair hey harry
and he was totally bald
that's why you see the games he was the
genie because they'd rub his head for
good luck
they actually robbed his head before the
immaculate reception and that's that's a
true story
so he was always the genie after that
the liftoff you'd say that you were at
that game i'm walking i was not at the
immaculate reception game no it was not
my first live game was in 1976.
actually it was it was tampa bay versus
the steelers they won
42 nothing in a blizzard no sam huff the
quarterback was doug williams there
i don't remember i was like six years
old it was just a blizzard and
everyone was mad that we went that's
when my dad would go to every game no
matter
now if it's like raining in ah in in
early october yeah it's a little chilly
outside i'm going to stay home
but before because he waited 40 years to
see a winner right
but just that's just how i feel like and
women too especially that an old
girlfriend of mine was like
she was like i love sara or whether her
name was like sarah sarah's a great
friend of mine she's my friend i'm like
she's a [ __ ]
i'm like don't don't deal with her we
broke up
three years later this girl comes with
me goes you were so right about
sarah she was such a [ __ ] i'm like i
told you
i can just but other people in hollywood
are they were like
they're they're nice to everybody
because they worry what if that guy gets
a tonight show and then he'll be
like really who gives a [ __ ] like life's
too short if he's a dick now he'll be a
dick then i don't really care like i'm
friends with who i want to be friends
with all right but i'm nice i'm pretty
much nice to everybody though
i'm just not their friends no no i would
i would 100 agree with that before we
get too deep into the podcast we're
going to talk football the whole time i
mean i guess there's not a lot to talk
about about [ __ ] hockey but uh
and it was saturday i've been kind of
blaming the owners because it's been a
lockout and they agreed to a deal but
someone was giving me [ __ ] on twitter
saying did you see this [ __ ] the players
did now are
you still on the players side i hope not
and i haven't really been paying
attention last time i paid attention
they were down to like
you know players were going from 57
percent to down to 53.
i have three things to say about the
hockey thing one is
why doesn't just i know lemieux saved
hockey three times but he's to come back
again
what is it lemieux shanahan holly and
steve eiserman
just get in a room and just say you know
what we you know this is the [ __ ]
game
here's the deal just play hockey and
that's it but the two things i do want
to say is like you know
the other for like a month i'm like it's
dark outside i need to be watching five
games
like i'm shaking then last week i just
was like you know what
i'm reading the book i don't i don't
miss it and you know what nhl
if i'm not missing it who the hell is
going to be watching like carolina
ottawa
on foxpoor south to alternate
okay you know you're the one who got me
back in the hospital yeah like if i'm
not watching it who's
who's coming back the really sad thing
is my daughter for christmas got this
doll
that's like the super doll that you have
to knife to buy 80 outfits for
so my sister was like i'm gonna buy her
a penguin outfit
the lady in pittsburgh is like oh we're
not making penguin outfits this year
because of the strike [ __ ] i'll get her
a steeler one so that's just how far
down like everything is like hockey just
gets lower
and lower now because of the strength so
stupid and they made more money than
they ever made
they had they have the winner classic
dude nhl hockey has not been on network
television on nbc cbs or abc
has not been on it the entire time i've
watched it it was on in the 70s the
worst time they could have made the deal
when it was just absolutely a [ __ ]
bar room brawl
every um every game you know something
this is the one thing
the only thing i like there's two things
i like about the montreal canadiens
being a a bruins fan one was when they
booed patrick wah
and he said [ __ ] you guys i'm never
playing here again because that really
[ __ ] that franchise right and he goes
to win two with the avalanche
which were the nordics so that could
piss off canadians with the uh the the
ray boar
cup yeah yeah it was awful wait what do
you think about that though
um i actually i don't have a problem
with it because let me get to the
other thing okay okay the other thing
about that i love was when [ __ ] uh
larry robinson beat the [ __ ] out of dave
schultz
just yeah at the canadiens run where he
was just standing up to him he's like
all right buddy you want to play this
[ __ ] game
no that's i mean you you you know mike i
love that
you know my hatred for the flyers oh
it's it's legendary
pittsburgh pittsburgh and philly they
they're in the same state they that's
hatfield and mccoy
yeah that's just that is that's the only
rivalry pittsburgh
has because people like one of the the
browns is like oh you're not robbery
with your doormat the ravens they're
like new and
who who cares i mean the flyers and the
penguins we
we used to be opher nixon we were like
over watergate in the spectrum to like
88.
i mean it's just i mean that's and then
and their fans
and their fans hated lemieux but then
they actually cheered to me when he came
back for cancer
they hate crosby a lot of fans say
crosby but they hate crosby
and he crosby just sticks it to him
today yeah
that's just the thing some people have
do have a hateable face
crosby has he has sort of a danny ainge
pouty face that's
that unless he's your guy you're not
gonna like it he's he's the best
so it's like lebron people just they're
get there's haters no they're already
exactly they're already gonna [ __ ]
hate him yeah but he
he's so much he's so much easier to hate
because there's something about his face
it'd be like
eli manning would be so much more
respected he would be at least
considered
at aaron rodgers level which i think he
finally is after that second one but
like it was his face
his f he just doesn't look like you know
he doesn't have like that [ __ ] uh
everything's gonna be okay i'm banging
the [ __ ] captain of the cheerleaders
[ __ ] uh yeah in high school
maybe hooked up with a teacher just that
[ __ ] you know that [ __ ] five
o'clock shadow the gunslinger
he doesn't have that look luck has that
look
like luck you know something i realized
i uh
because the fact that actually like
andrew luck and actually like the colts
now
i actually realized that i never really
even hated peyton manning i just hated
that tom brady that wasn't getting the
respect because now like i'm watching
time i'm watching peyton manning
with uh the broncos and i'm rooting for
him and i actually think the patriots
dude
i mean i don't know if you beat the
dolphins at this point it was close but
like i'd say
we already beat broncos this year we got
a 50 50 chance
of of of of losing [ __ ] uh
we played them in the playoffs because
he's he's so gelled with that team now
oh the they're good the broncos are good
i mean
anybody but i mean anybody but houston
give me a break i'm saying houston
houston i mean like give me
do you want your old school hatred of
the oil oh i know the houston oilers
number one
i used to have this shirt that had the
little iron on from the mall
that had uh bum phillips beat on the
door that said super bowl
and jack lambert's in front of it just
holding it back like like uh
bomb knocking on the super bowl door
like they won't let him in oh dude if
you still had that that's [ __ ]
legendary the sweat rings would be right
through it but uh
no i mean i just houston certainly i
mean like i mean the students are down
here but i mean like i
the thing about the afc to me is like
you always either go through pittsburgh
or you got to go through the baltimore
because unless you unless you can look
james harrison
and paula malalu in the face and say
we're going super bowl or you can look
uncle ray in the face
right then you you haven't really beaten
you haven't played man football
and houston schwab really schwa is
schweither you think bill belichick is
going to let
schwab go to this but there's a thing
about the patriots so we we put up
gaudy number i feel like we're the
patriots right now we're like how the
colts were
back in the day when when peyton manning
they would go 13-3 or 12 and four and
then lose in the first round we don't
lose in the first round but like
like we're not going to play the bills
we're not going to play the jets in
january so who gives a [ __ ] that we put
up 50 [ __ ] points
it inflates your stats and it makes
everybody think that you're this
juggernaut
and the best thing our secondary has
going for it
is our running game because it can chew
up the clock and keeps them
off the field as long as possible
because dude we [ __ ] let up like 300
yards that
bum and [ __ ] buffalo whatever the
[ __ ] his name is
patrick yeah he's out there like he's
[ __ ] uh starback
his contract is his country it's
horrible
his country is like 10 years for all
this money yeah
he's like just not a good
that goes back to that ray book thing
where you're going to ask me like how i
felt about it
like you had to understand that that the
bruins fan base was so
loyal it didn't matter that we weren't
winning cups they were still going to
sell it out
and cinnamon and those guys were just
cheap [ __ ] and they would never just
make that extra move
to get us over the top and ray stayed
with us dude
from 1979 to
june of 2000 and he went through i don't
know how many rebuildings
especially in the the 90s when we really
started falling off he went through he
he [ __ ] what was he supposed to do
he had one more year left there was no
[ __ ] way we were going to win it
and that was they did him a solid they
traded him to a contender
and they still had to go out and win it
the only thing i didn't like
and i know his heart was in the right
place but when he finally won the cup
he brought the cup back to boston as
like a show of hey man you know here's
the stanley cup
and it's just like i know his heart was
in the right place but it was brutal
it's like yeah
it's this thing you haven't [ __ ] won
in 30 28 years at that point yeah 28
years
but um but so i don't have i don't have
a problem it was cool he went to denver
too so it's like a new city it wasn't
like he went to like
oh i would say the flyers but like he
went to like the rangers or someone
that's just like
oh look you've hated him for 30 years
now he's like yeah i don't i don't get
mad at all denver didn't even have a
team like ray allen going to miami it
doesn't bug me like people actually get
like pissed like he was one of our guys
it's like he wasn't
he was he was a free agent he's he's jim
calhoun's guy
i don't i don't you know way more than
me oh well i mean hoop is uh hoop is
and it's so sad talk about the demise of
the nfl the biggest demise is demise of
the big east
why now huh big expect college
basketball were you supposed to talk
about that
yeah oh we still can't it's the great i
used to watch that all the time [ __ ]
georgetown chris mullen
pete i mean whatever people say
washington i read that book oh you know
nascar and no you know what you know
what
invented espn was the big east
because then they had no stupid
programming in the afternoon you didn't
have like uh
michelle beale on in the afternoon
talking let's see what colin coward
thinks like who gives a [ __ ] what that
guy thinks
they they just ran biggies basketball
games again in the afternoon
so when you're out all night in high
school playing then you just stay home
from school the next day and watch the
big east all afternoon my grandmother
let me stay home from school all the
time i just watched the big east
it was the best i used to go to new york
too and you go to new york to see the
tournaments yeah
absolutely so you saw ewing and uh i saw
i i saw
two years in a row i saw the patrick
ewing the year that they won the big
east championship
we actually saw them in laguardia their
whole
team and my dad still pissed this day
because i became a knicks fan because i
love pat
but ewing didn't give me an autograph my
dad wanted to sucker punch him
he didn't give you an autograph no the
whole team so bill martin who was the
power forward back then gave me an
autograph
but these guys were huge and thompson
was the biggest on them all
and thompson goes who wants lunch horns
remember horns broadnax
he'd a stack a hundred dollar bills like
john gotti
just ripping them off giving giving them
the players jesus christ and then
two seconds later andre the giant walk
past
and i swear to god uh i'm almost ready
to call [ __ ]
story size what i can call my dad except
he's he's like you know panicking over
the colts
baltimore i said colts that's how old
school i am
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah i you know
he's already happy i interrupted it once
again
he's already half into a bottle of uh
jay and big or some whatever
my dad like he likes to mix it up i
respect that he you know he changes it
up some days but he marries somebody's
you never know he's there there you go
so
go back to andre i always interrupt your
great stories no so uh
so literally uh just right after that we
walk up andre the giant walks back and
obviously john thompson was bigger
shoulder-wise than him but he walks by
just how big he was he actually ducked
at a sign in laguardia
no airport signs like she can see him
from yeah he's like six ten
no he's like seven four who is andre the
giant
i'm sorry i thought you were talking
about oh no john thompson yeah he's
backed up building
all right that's how he knows how to
play center because he worked with him
yeah the giant they had a thing in
sports illustrated one time when they
would they were just
uh they talked about you know all the
[ __ ] he he would do as a joke like
he would like uh somebody's car he would
like turn it around and face it
make it facing the other way and they
showed him like one night he allegedly
drank like 100 beers and they showed him
when he holds a 12-ounce beer can in his
hand
like the top of the can is flush with
like if you hold your hand sideways the
way you would hold the beer
like from the top of his hand to the
bottom of his hand is the whole beer he
could fit a 12-ounce can in there it
literally looked
it wasn't even like a pony it looked
like half a pony shot so it's just like
yeah this is like him
doing like three swallows he'd be done
with it still 100 beers are still
[ __ ]
respectful but uh he's one of the
greatest biographies on a
e ever because right when he was gonna
die like four months left he just went
back to his hometown and just played
cards
with all of his friends until he died
just like just bought like a cabin just
like yeah come on over i got a kegger
just playing cards i think it's that's
[ __ ] awesome you know you know
without bad i hope i go out like that
right now because you know there's
something to be said about dying
peacefully like in your
in your sleep and not realizing it but
there's also there is something
if you've lived long enough and you've
done you know
you had the kids you get you you went
after your dream you did all that stuff
been just whatever did did [ __ ] you
wanted to do and
was the most recognizable human being on
the face of the earth
and so that's the only thing that andre
accomplished in his wikipedia page
that's right he was that's unreal yeah
he's even like bigger than jordan
like literally bigger than john well i
mean they still have those [ __ ]
stickers that obey thing
you see that's his face that they have
all the way around there but i would
love to go out like that and just be
like
when you're like [ __ ] 85 and they
just go all right you have three months
to live
and you're like cool and enough of your
friends are left that's the one thing
dude
if you live too long you [ __ ] outlive
all your friends i just said my
grandmother god bless her she just uh
she passed away just shy of her 105th
birthday dude she was on
her third set of friend like generation
like she outlived
i mean it's just unbelievable i mean uh
you know she played bridge kept her mind
sharp and she had to just keep getting
new friends
she outlived my grandfather by [ __ ]
25 years
25 [ __ ] they were married for 62
years whoa
i mean they eloped when they were like
you know 16 17 like way back in the day
you could back then where you were like
i think we're going to move in together
for a while
let's see how it goes we're gonna get a
dog and then if we can do that then you
know yeah yeah yeah no no they uh no
that's like you and you wanna do
anything you better be married
exactly that was exactly it yeah so they
eloped but yeah so they made because i
remember going to their 60th anniversary
that was like in the [ __ ] 80s dude
that was like 84 85 my grandfather
passed in 87
and then she lived all the way to 2012
but that's the thing that is you you
actually you end up like
you you outlet everybody somebody was
telling me last night i'm working with
todd rex
who i got to get on this podcast t-rex
todd yeah t-rex is one of the funniest
[ __ ]
ever oh that's that story i told on this
podcast you know he says
hey what do you say they're handsome you
know he says that [ __ ]
we uh we got pulled over because his
windows were too tinted or something
this guy pulls us over
we're on the 101 the guy you know the
guy's talking on the cops talking on the
loudspeaker he goes you know uh
get off at the next exit and that got us
on to the 110. now we're on
we're on our way to the bray improv it's
now on the 110
we have to drive a quarter of a mile to
get to the next [ __ ] exit we get off
we're literally like five miles away
from where the [ __ ] we were
we pull off and for some reason he has
to stop under the [ __ ]
overpass it's raining right so i don't
know what we're underneath the thing
and todd's been silly all week never
seen any anger now
first time seeing him like [ __ ] angry
right and this babyface cop comes
walking up
and he todd doesn't give a [ __ ] puts the
window down there's the cop comes
walking up
license is ready he goes hey what do you
say there handsome
dude we just start [ __ ] bursting out
laughing
and the cop stood there and he kind of
looked i guess he watched comedy central
so he recognized someone in the car and
then he recognized todd
and then he literally got on his [ __ ]
heels like oh [ __ ] you guys are comics
we just started laughing and he actually
let us go you know i don't want to tell
too much more because he ended up being
like a really good [ __ ] about it i don't
get the guy in trouble and uh you know
um but whatever i'm working with you
didn't find the heroine in the trunk is
what you're saying
no i'm saying maybe a few weeks later
somebody
you know had a [ __ ] moving violation
and maybe he did something to make it go
away he was a good [ __ ]
oh right well there's nothing like good
cops
well thank god he was a good guy because
i even if the guy was like a [ __ ]
old school i'm going to shoot you and
plant a gun on you
todd t-rex still would have said the
same [ __ ] well those
say they had some that's the problem in
los angeles on the west coast san
francisco's got some old school city
cops
and they're cool but and they let me off
the hook on a couple dui's
but i mean like old pittsburgh cops were
the best for duis
just like yeah i go home like you all
right
good get out of here i mean there's
nothing black or white
old school city cops are the best
because they don't give a [ __ ]
they've dealt with everything it's
always like the young like straight out
of the academy we're in desert storm
republican kids or
collar or or or the broads they're the
worst cops
but the old school men they don't give a
[ __ ] they're over
i mean i mean the worst was one time i
just we just did a
partying our ass off in new york city
i'm coming back out of new york on like
interstate 80 or 280
whatever going through jersey to get to
pennsylvania and
um you know when you're just in that
morning the sun comes up and you're
still just
gagged and just like drunk and right
it's like 10 lanes of traffic
i didn't know i was actually in the 11th
lane
in the middle like i know i wasn't
paying i didn't know
and i'm like why is this cop just
sitting it stopped in the middle of the
freeway here it was the center lane
what were you in like the breakdown yeah
like i was in the middle like whatever
like right next to the wall i mean like
the medium
yeah the median strip lane yeah the that
lane so it's not grass it is paved but
no it's paved yeah i'm thinking like
what's that cop doing sitting there
so then i pull over and then i'm like i
swerve out of the way and keep driving
all right pulls you over pulls me over
and at the time my car
my window didn't work so i had so like i
went to open the door to get
the if i kicked it in there's there was
like i think when i trade the car in the
boot print of the new jersey state
trooper
was still in the car here it was his
first monday back he'd been hit by a
drunk driver he was out
eight months oh no but it was so early
in the morning
on a monday morning in rush hour he just
couldn't believe that i was drunk
yeah so he just yeah he's just like
what's wrong with you and i'm like i
didn't see
it says you know strung out and he's
like or whatever i said
he's like you know i like they had the
pencil nothing like out of state plates
like i'm the [ __ ]
they don't have this stuff in our state
i didn't know you couldn't drive on the
[ __ ] medium strip
pennsylvania that's legal we only got
three lanes you're like a big city
officer i don't really know but that's
that's why i don't drink and drive ever
anymore because i've been pulled i got
literally got off
that's why not because you don't want to
kill somebody it's because you don't
want to well i mean
i don't want to waste 10 grand
that should be the thing how much did
that last shot cost me
10 grand i mean obviously i don't want
to hurt anybody
but i got busted for that [ __ ] in 89
december of 89.
it was it was a dude it was a layup it
was a layup i was so [ __ ] drunk i
couldn't even get my [ __ ]
i wasn't even nervous that's how drunk i
was i was like all right you got me but
that's that's
that's stumbled through the i blew up
one nine that's the problem
that's the problem nowadays though it's
like hey you know if you're that [ __ ]
up and like
like i said i was like five or six times
out of my mind
and then each time i left the hook
that's why i was like you know what
that's it i can't do anything all right
did you ever get busted for it or no
no i was always i always like knew the
cop or my boss knew the cop was always
in pittsburgh
in pittsburgh it was five times
legitimately like just off the hook like
ah yeah i know you or blah blah blah
with our friend
you know one time i was i was coming
home from a christmas party i was
working in this warehouse
we were underage and me and this other
guy sarge was his nickname we got we got
absolutely [ __ ] hammered and we were
driving his mother's like pontiac grand
am you remember those things oh yeah in
the 80s what they look like with that
plastic [ __ ] they're like they're like
this chevy celebrity
yeah except for pond yeah by pontiac
exactly so we were driving right through
the center of town
and uh there was this jeep sitting at
the old school cj7 when they made them
like out of [ __ ] steel and the guy
stopped at the red light i got a bear
between my legs you know drinking and
the other guy's [ __ ] he's
we're hammered we both see it we see it
he starts to slow down
he just didn't press the brakes hard
enough we just sort of
oh bam slammed into it right and this
[ __ ] had all like the brand new safety
on it so the engine [ __ ] drops down
under the [ __ ]
just the whole thing just crumpled up
i've slammed my head off the visor
beer just goes all over me covered in
[ __ ] beer we're right in the center
of town in my hometown
[ __ ] cops are they like and it was so
funny the whole the [ __ ] grand am was
totaled
there was like just a scratch on the
back bumper the cj7 like i don't even
think the [ __ ] guy
like he barely noticed he was sitting in
the jeep he got out right
cops are there in like [ __ ] two
seconds they show i'm literally covered
in beer
and the cop just you know standing there
he goes you guys been drinking
like no no i haven't drink it at all
right dude [ __ ] beer shower
so we stand down he goes yeah he goes
his car wreaks alcohol get out of the
car we're like fine
so i'm standing there on the sidewalk on
the other side of the jeep with this
dude sarge
covered in [ __ ] i'm i'm so drenched
in beer i'm actually cold
cause it's like [ __ ] like 30 degrees
out i'm soaking wet
and i'm sitting there like and i already
been through i know i hadn't been
through my [ __ ] yet
i hadn't got arrested yet so i for
drinking and driving so i'm sitting
there talking to sarge i'm just going
dude i'll give a [ __ ] if they arrest you
i'll go to court i'll lie under oath i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll say you weren't
drinking i got you back i'm [ __ ]
alive for you said all this [ __ ]
and then when i was done i turned and
faced the street and there was a cop
sitting in the cruiser
staring right at me i i when i thought
heard the whole thing to this day i
can't believe he didn't get [ __ ]
arrested
yeah he didn't get [ __ ] i don't know
what happened i have no [ __ ] idea
i had the empty beer there was beer all
over the windshield
all over me somehow we got out of it he
didn't get he didn't get busted i
remember my dad picked me up
and at that point i was smart enough to
shut the [ __ ] up and he picked me up
dude i mean i'm like
swaying in the wind the car smashed
and i get in the car just covered in
beer and he's just like uh
how are you doing you all right i was
just like yeah yeah i'm good i'm good i
didn't say [ __ ] i think he wasn't mad at
me because i wasn't driving and we just
[ __ ] drove home but yeah
but that was the 80s everybody that's
that's what happened yeah they let you
go
dads are so cool about that stuff in
general it's like oh it wasn't it wasn't
my car it wasn't like yeah [ __ ] happens
like who
like what dad hasn't been the passenger
in a drunk driving incident no my dad my
dad was in
the navy and he was in a frat so he has
and he did that [ __ ] in the 60s so
i mean when i finally got busted for
drinking and driving uh
my dad was totally cool my mother was
upset and that that was their dynamic
like
little [ __ ] my dad flipped out like guys
get upstairs and [ __ ] clean up your
room
but big [ __ ] you got arrested for
drinking and driving he was just like
you all right all right cool well
[ __ ] blah blah my mother was the
opposite she let the little [ __ ] go and
then the big stuff
i just remember dude my dad woke me up
like
they bailed me out of [ __ ] jail and
uh
i'm still [ __ ] hammered they [ __ ]
takes me home by the time i get home
it's like [ __ ] maybe like four in the
morning
i go to sleep my dad wakes me up at
seven in the morning
all right three [ __ ] hours later i'm
like still just
ham i'm still going up yeah that's how
drunk i was and he goes
i think should go downstairs and uh tell
your mother what you did you know that
old school [ __ ] so i [ __ ] stumbled
downstairs my mother already knows
hammered out of my mind like i got her
drinking and driving and she had this
[ __ ] look of pain on her face it was
brutal
it was [ __ ] brutal then i went back
upstairs and i probably slept till like
two
and uh i only got 45 days though 45 days
is all you got back there now it's like
[ __ ] 90 days or like six months
we're not making light of this by the
way people we realize this is a serious
crime
but oh yeah please take a cab i mean
that's what gets me about
when these athletes like there's nothing
i love better than being driven around
i mean like me and now magic will
actually have a thing like we would we
have a race
in our careers and obviously he's way
ahead uh the first one dude
on the daily show and one of the uh the
founders of this company the podcast
company
the record company that the cd salute is
coming out on
yeah please by the way everybody go on
amazon down can they download it
anywhere
yeah they can download it from amazon i
believe and buy it from amazon
it's on everything but itunes literally
everything but i think and when joe says
these are his classic jokes like the
first time i
i worked with you met you was in the
punch line
in san francisco molly had booked you
and she goes you i think you're going to
like this guy dude within five minutes i
was like not only do i love his mature i
[ __ ] love this guy
you would like every one of your jokes
especially in san francisco how liberal
it is
would totally be offensive and you'd
feel the crowd pull back and then you
would just keep
tagging the punchline with even more
offensive [ __ ] and they just had to just
give in
like this guy just doesn't give a [ __ ]
it was i
i just remember that one you did about
the chick sucking dick
for something what the hell was that one
you would run from the side of the stage
going
oh that's timing sucking a dick the
difference between l.a and san francisco
that's my differences
i just remember it was so loud and it
was so [ __ ]
graphic and everybody was just like
pulling back and you just kept doing it
running from side to side
miming sucking a dick to get your
[ __ ] career going
and it was just it was so [ __ ] over
the top it was it was awesome man it was
awesome so i really hope
that people are going to do the right
thing and you know something like
and and speaking of doing the right
thing dude uh we uh me and some of my
friends we put together
uh a benefit for uh the late great
patrice o'neal in new york city
tickets went on sale on uh thursday and
i know a lot of my podcast listeners are
gonna give me [ __ ] for not announcing it
on monday but there's a reason why i
wait till thursday thursday was the one
year
anniversary of patrice's death and
i just feel like the stuff that opie and
anthony did for him like they
they just had like there's just hours
and hours of stuff for patrice
oh and this show is ridiculously amazing
what's that the benefit show oh the show
yeah we're doing it oh yeah i mean yeah
yeah
that show could be held in the astrodome
yeah it's that good
i mean it's really it's so it sold out
it sold out in
24 hours and um you know i i was able to
tell patrice's mom and it's the happiest
i've heard of since all this whole
[ __ ] awful scenario started so i want
to thank everybody
o a fans and everybody who saw it on
twitter who went and bought tickets uh
you really [ __ ] did a great thing by
buying those tickets and it's going to
be a [ __ ] awesome show
so um anyways um
i don't know where the [ __ ] to go with
with that so do another solid here
i know i didn't bring it up uh but the
o'neill tickets so if you want to
[ __ ] do a solid
joey b salute
from the all things comedy network dude
we're at hour and seven this has been
[ __ ] effortless you've been a great
[ __ ] guest
thank you we had so much fun we had like
hours so i forgot i was holding the
microphone actually it's like we're so
used to uh
bullshitting well let's talk [ __ ]
rose bowl well uh
what do you think stanford wisconsin i
was working with nate craig last night
uh
one of the guys you played hockey with
he's he's open out there he was he was
saying wisconsin stinks he's like we
stink
well it won like a thousand i mean you
know
honestly about the rose bowl the least
the most
the thing i hate the thing i like the
least about the rose bowl is the game
i actually it's like a drag oh there's
going to be a game
oh you know i mean it's like you have so
much fun
in the parking lot i'm telling you the
parking lot by the way people is a
[ __ ] golf course
you owe it to yourself at some point in
your life
if you've ever wanted to go to the rose
bowl i'm telling you the tailgate is
better and do it up
bring somebody who knows how to cook
bring a bunch of booze
and you're just sitting there it dude
it's it's the greatest [ __ ] way ever
to start the year
all those years are doing stand-up and
going on stage where they gave the
noisemakers out to the crowd before you
go
up in absolute hell and then like the
[ __ ] clock strikes whatever
and you gotta do the countdown okay you
[ __ ] animals
ten nine all those years of doing that
[ __ ] and just i don't even know how the
[ __ ] we ended up talking about it we
just bought it that's the greatest [ __ ]
we went today we went to that amazing
tennessee ucla game when tennessee was
up like 20 to nothing and we're like we
could leave at halftime this game's over
we stayed
you say like made the comeback and we're
like we gotta go to the rose bowl this
place is amazing
right and then we had the ultimate
experience of the first year second year
we brought along jason
jason had showed up and if you don't
know jason lawhead unfortunately he's
not the trademark
batting stance guy he got he like it's
like someone stole the formula and then
he got screwed out of it
but lawhead can do the big red machine
batting stances reggie jackson he won't
let me post to reggie jackson
because he said he was out of shape when
he did it oh he
dude his that reggie jackson thing he
does this reggie jackson he
he goes when do you want to see him do
you want to see him when he's younger or
when he's older
he does the hall he does the home run he
hit in the [ __ ] all-star game
dude when he stands up there right i'm
standing up now for people listening
here obviously
he [ __ ] when he does that thing where
he he brings the bat up and then [ __ ]
adjusts the glasses
dude the second he did that i was like
it's [ __ ] reggie
the fact he can do the whole big red
machine but to me my favorite is pete
rose's uh when he when he beat ty cobb
he does he does him rounding first base
the clap the the the handshake it's the
anyway he showed up all the way to
crying on his son's shoulder yes
he does he does the whole awkwardness at
first base
and how great is it when he does like
i'm like and he does like pete rose's
stance yeah where he's sitting there
crouching down and he literally does
what about when he did he did willie
mcgee he had his dying laughing doing
willie mcgee
and when he does the swing we're on the
[ __ ] ground laughing
and then his classic quote he goes he
loved the high fastball didn't he
it's like i don't know jay did he it
looked just like him so
so he joined the crew then we have
andrew join the queue now this is the
fifth year anniversary
this is it yeah this is the fifth year
anniversary so
what do you think do you think
stanford's just going to come in and
pound them uh
i think stanford has a better team but
you never know they take like a month
off it's like
it's like when you don't go on stage for
a month you never really know even
though you know your jokes you don't
really
[Music]
stanford should burn those uniforms they
played in uh last week
that flat black helmet that was just
[ __ ] oh the black on black
yeah that was that designed by jay-z it
was terrible
because if jay-z did it it would have
been the [ __ ] have you seen the [ __ ]
bar play center
you know annoying that is a celtics fan
we got 17 [ __ ] banners
we just went down to home depot bought a
bunch of cinder blocks and built a
[ __ ] square
dude barclay center the hardwood floor
is supposed to be like a brown stone in
brooklyn if you have a nice one and you
redo it
right and the luxury boxes are like mini
[ __ ] brownies yeah
i i'm just kind of not into cities with
two teams
i just kind of like you know what move
somewhere else give give somebody
how you can be a lifelong knick fan go
through
coming this close to winning the
championship with pat riley the finger
you